die ganze zeit als ich mir das angeguckt
hat mich ein gefühl beschlichen dass
eine regierungskoalition von der
überhaupt nicht geredet wird vielleicht
am ende die ist die wieder kommt und das
ist die große koalition also überlegt
euch doch das mal wir reden jetzt
ständig in diesen dreier bündnissen es
gibt aber ein zweierbündnis das reicht
vielleicht 26 und 24 sind 50 oder man
also das bedeutet ich glaube das lasche
bereits auch die variante in betracht
zieht der juniorpartner der spd in einer
großen koalition zu sein und dann sagen
kann wir hatten einen verrückten
wahlkampf wir haben gekämpft bis zum
schluss und es ist mir noch gelungen die
cdu in der regierung zu halten
sensationell das könnte doch auch der
grund sein warum er da nicht so auf
wandelt wie mir saß und er wird wieder
dieses offensichtlich ist dass der
wunsch der bürgerinnen und bürger den
willen der bürger gestalten den
wählerwillen
genau das ist das was ich überhaupt
vermisse in diesem gesamten wahlkampf
ich habe ja einige in amerika miterlebte
haben männer mit mid mid mid mid vor
zorn geschwollenem hans worten ich werde
wohl größeren dorf das country- und mit
dieser prämisse marschieren die ein ich
habe bei keinem dieser drei menschen die
leidenschaft erlebt die ich mir wünsche
von meinem zukünftigen kanzler
schrägstrich kanzlerin
[Musik]